MARK
MARK, CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
BOOK.
IT GETS TO A CENTRAL QUESTIONS
IN THIS RACE AND MARYLAND AND SO
MANY RACES LEADING UP TO THE
MIDTERMS.
THAT IS YOU'VE GOT GOP
CANDIDATES FIGHTING FOR TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT IN PUBLIC, AND MANY
TELLING YOU DIFFERENT THINGS
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
>> YEAH.
THAT IS A CENTRAL DYNAMIC THAT
ANY REPORTER IN WASHINGTON HAS
EXPERIENCED, YOU KNOW, MANY,
MANY TIMES OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS WHICH IS THE CONTEMPT
BETWEEN WHAT PEOPLE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO DON'T HAVE
MUCH USE FOR TRUMP WILL SAY
ABOUT HIM IN PRIVATE VERSUS WHAT
THEY WILL SAY IN PUBLIC ABOUT
HIM, WHICH IS JUST LIKE
UNBRIDLED IS HUGE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT AS STEXTREMES
NOW AND I ASSUME YOU GUYS ARE IN
THE SAME BOAT.
IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
>> WHAT THEY SAY AND WHAT THEY
DO.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN SAID HE
DID IT OR OTHERWISE HE WOULD
LOSE HIS SEAT.
YOU QUOTE A CONVERSATION WITH A
FORMER REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
WHO SAID, INTERESTING PLAN HERE.
THE PARTY'S ONLY REAL PLAN FOR
DEALING WITH TRUMP IN 2024
INVOLVED A DARKLY DIVINE
INTERVENTION AND WE ARE JUST
WAITING FOR HIM TO DIE.
THAT WAS IT.
THAT WAS THE PLAN.
HE WAS 100% SERIOUS.
FIRST OF ALL, THAT IS PRETTY
DARK.
>> PRETTY DARK, YEAH.
>> GOP POLITICIANS ARE TAKING UP
TRUMP'S MANTEL ON A NUMBER OF
ISSUES, DOES TRUMPISM, DO
BELIEVE TRUMPISM DIES WITH
TRUMP?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SEED HE HAS
PLANTED ACROSS THE COUNTRY, A
LOT OF JUNIOR TRUMPS ARE OUT
THERE NOW.
WE TALKED JUST ABOUT THIS.
THEY ARE ON BALLOTS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND THEY ARE WINNING
NOMINATIONS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE ENDORSED
BY TRUMP.
HE HAS INTRODUCED A MINDSET INTO
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT IS NOT
EASY TO WORK WITH IF YOU'RE A
CONVENTIONAL REPUBLICAN OR IF
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT AND, YOU KNOW,
THE WHOLE ETHIC THERE IS JUST
WHATEVER WE DO IS GOING TO
PREVAIL.
I THINK IN SOME WAYS, I THINK
WHAT WE ARE DESCRIBING HERE IS
IN SOME WAYS, AUTHORITARIANISM.
I THINK A LOT OF THESE
REPUBLICANS WHO -- A LOT OF THEM
ARE NEW AND LOA LOT OF THEM ARE
RANK IN FILE AND THERAPY BEING
OWE BEA
WAY TO GET IN LINE.
IT'S NOT WHAT WE ARE USED TO IN
OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM.
I TALKED TO AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE IN MY BOOK AND SORT OF
TALK ABOUT HOW THIS SUBMISSION
HAPPENS.
ANYTHING WHO HAS BEEN IN
WASHINGTON KNOWS THIS IS THE
DOMINANT STORY IN WASHINGTON THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS MORE SO THAN
I THINK TRUMP, HIMSELF.
>> YOU SAID SOMETHING TO OUR
RYAN NOBLES.
THAT IS LOOKING BACK AT THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION IS EVEN
SCARIER NOW IN RETROSPECT.
>> WE ARE DIDN'T KNOW THE FULL
EXTENT THAT LIVES WERE IN DANGER
AND MORE LIVES ARE IN DANGER.
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS APPARENTLY
QUITE INVOLVED IN IT.
SO THAT IS SCARY.
BUT, ALSO, WHAT IS EVEN MORE
SCARIER IS WHAT YOU LOOK WHAT
HAS GONE ON THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF.
THE FACT THAT TRUMP HAS SURVIVED
IT AND THE FACT THAT TRUMP IS AS
STRONG INSIDE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IT SEEMS AS HE WAS EVEN
AFTER THE ELECTION WHEN YOU
WOULD THINK THAT A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WOULD HAVE AN EASY
OFF RAMP TO HIM, I MEAN, IT'S
JUST A REMARKABLE THING IF YOU
EVER STAND BACK AND THINK ABOUT
IT TO SURVIVE AND HE SURVIVED
THIS POLITICALLY.
THE IDEA THAT, YOU KNOW,
DEMOCRATS WOULD GO KISS THE RING
OF JIMMY CARTER AFTER HE WAS
ANNIHILATED IN THE ELECTION IS
AB
BIZARRE BUT DONALD TRUMP PLAYS
BY DIFFERENT RULES.
>> 56 HUNDREDS COMMITTED CRIMES
IN HIS NAME, RIGHT?
THE BOOK IS "THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVITUDE DONALD TRUMP'S
WASHINGTON AND THE PRICE OF
SUBMISSION."
IT'S A GOOD READ.
THANKS FOR COMING OUT.
>> THANKS.